japanese cuisine i feel like exploded
during my lifetime it wasn't that big
when i was growing up
but now it's like in the uk do you think
so i feel like we still only really have
like sushi in the uk
yeah there's the occasional ramen place
nothing like
worth getting super excited the us has
completely taken that
was everywhere yeah but there wasn't a
single ramen restaurant in america where
i'm like
this is good yeah me neither i mean it
would be hard right
all of them well to be fair i in vegas i
did go to a place a ramen place which
dead ass was called naruto
that gets points just for that yeah and
i was like aki why are we not eating
there every day
it's [ __ ] amazing i became so picky
with ramen here it's
so it's so easy to [ __ ] up i didn't
realize yeah it's like really
you know when you're not here and you're
not eating the ramen here you're like oh
yeah what's wrong isn't it same thing
and then when you come here and you're
like broth is four percent too salty
yeah yeah
the noodles were slightly undercooked
this is really embarrassing for you this
is your job
just become like an absolute [ __ ]
food snob when you live here longer yeah
right where it's like
i never used to give a [ __ ] about like
the type of ramen or the type of sushi
but yeah
yeah but now i'm like no no i only eat
one specific
sushi train franchise is it anywhere
else 100 yen sushi get that [ __ ] out of
here
so many of them [ __ ] up the pork like if
it's so like old and like tough and i'm
like what did you do to this part it has
to be like the perfect
yeah it has to be like the perfect
texture that just like kind of falls
apart in your mouth
yeah like i i find myself eating ramen a
lot less in japan than
i thought i would yeah like sushi
[ __ ] slapstick also i could eat that
any day also ramen [ __ ] takes you out
of business for the day like you can't
you can't do anything so heavy and it's
so bad for you like it's delicious but
like it's it's
extremely bad for you it's really bad
for you and like you you're not supposed
to drink the whole broth like that's the
killer
sorry i knew i looked at you for a
reason like i knew you were like white
guy of course
dude because when i go anywhere i'm like
i don't want to feel like i'm leaving
anything
all right i feel rude so i'm like i look
at the guy making i'm alright [ __ ] okay
i guess i would just drink the [ __ ]
dead sea but okay to be
fat yeah okay yes that okay the sodium
is through the roof sometimes some of
the bowls have like the thank you
message at the bottom if you drink it
is that what that's what they do that's
how they literally because i want to see
the thank you message
but most of the time there isn't and do
you get sad when you yeah actually i get
super i get real [ __ ] sad but i
did it for nothing i drink like a liter
of this thing i feel awful all day i
have to like lie down and then i didn't
even get a thank you thank you
i'd like to think that the guy is like
nice guy he made my life a little easier
he cleaned it but he didn't give a [ __ ]
he probably just gets the pressure
washer and then it's like clean
there we go oh god yeah
ramen you definitely get picky in japan
but that's also because
you know there's so much there's a lot
of factors to it right like is the ramen
too is the noodle too chewy
like is the broth too fatty but it's
also like personal
also sometimes also sometimes you get
like rushed and when it's super busy
you're like
oh yeah like if like all the famous
ramen places in tokyo always have lines
and you're like expect to eat it get the
[ __ ] out yeah you can't go with friends
because it's not really what it's for
because there's not gonna be like three
seats empty well i know you guys have
like
constantly told me how [ __ ] fast i
eat my ramen yeah
and it's like it's literally just been
i've been conditioned to eat it
joey [ __ ] vacuums is ramen because
i'm normally the one who eats super fast
and then it's really weird being with
joey where he just destroys the ramen
like hold up
because like i've been to when i was
still visiting here and my like
uncle would take me to like the best
[ __ ] like ramen and place he's like
we're leaving we're leaving right now
it's always like this this store can
only hold like three people sitting down
yeah so it's like you can't
and there's always like 20 people
waiting outside so it's like if you
dilly dally in here you're not going to
be welcome back
because you can't you can't talk with
your friends and you go in there because
it's like you got to eat
classic yeah yeah and actually it is a
skilledy robin really
really fast too it like scares people
but you know that slurping
that you're supposed to do that's that's
like a purposeful thing
yeah so you can just eat the whole thing
while it's piping hot yeah
which is like a really straight like
you're not you're not weirdly not there
to enjoy
it you just yeah it's there for a
purpose for a purpose
yeah like fill my stomach and get the
[ __ ] out yeah but there's some places
the ramen is so good that you're like i
need to take my time like i can't
you know i know which is like which is
why i'll try and go at like awkward
times like three p.m
yeah three because then you can normally
there's never a line it's like it's it's
you know
dinners no one's coming for dinner no
one's going for lunch right yeah so good
but that but then you then then you
[ __ ] up your eating spa like schedule
for them
right i always feel so ungraceful
getting out of the stools i'm like
i'm i look like i'm two months pregnant
and i gotta like like
like you can feel the soup just swishing
around
in your stomach the worst is if you're
getting on the train afterwards the
moment you sit down the train it's like
sleep is activated
it does rock you to sleep it really does
that food
but it's so good go eat it just don't go
to ichiran right no i like it shiran is
good